hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to share with
you how i became a millionaire by age 25
and hopefully when i teach this and
share this and tell you what i did
you'll be inspired and there's been the
crazy thing is because i am one of those
people that has to share everything i'm
doing like if i watch a good movie i'm
trying to get my whole family to watch
the movie if i go to a good restaurant
i'm telling my whole family and my whole
friends go eat in this restaurant i'm
giving the restaurant loads of free
promotions because i enjoyed it and in
the same way when i became a millionaire
i started with nothing and i'm like wow
i failed in school and now i've become a
millionaire and i told all my friends my
family now my whole family my brother my
parents my sister
you know everyone's doing what i'm doing
and everyone's making money in property
and it's i feel like i broke the chain
and a lot of rich people when they
become wealthy they just hide away and
you don't really hear from them they
don't really share but i always vouch
never to do that and in this video i'm
going to talk about how i became a
millionaire
which i actually achieved by age 25.
now i'm a multi-millionaire of because
when you do it once
when you become a millionaire it's not
difficult to do it again you know it's
like anything you know if you learn the
hard bit if you're learning to drive
it's hard to learn to drive but once
you've learned to drive and you can go
to work in your car you can do it over
and over and over again because you
learned how to do it and you know get
real satisfaction from teaching people
how to
become their own boss how to get on the
property ladder and um i'm going to talk
to you about how i can millionaire so
how did i become a millionaire well i
actually created a strategy and
i created this when i was about 23 23
years old and this thing that i created
this service that i created just banged
and blew up all across the uk and it
made me a millionaire and that thing
that i created was
deal selling okay packaging and selling
deals now the reason i created it was
because no one was doing it back then
like no one was doing youtube videos
about how to be a deal seller
packager package and sell deals wasn't a
thing okay and
what i realized was when i was like 23
because i bought a few houses you know
so by the time i was 23
i owned quite a few houses i bought them
on
purchase lease option agreements i'd
like partnered i joined ventured i
borrowed money from people i was in a
lot of debt but i did own assets and i
knew
how to find good deals
and what i did was
i started finding deals but rather than
buying them myself because you can't you
can i can't buy every deal i see it
costs a lot of money to buy a deal if
you're buying a house damn you're gonna
need like tens and tens of thousands of
pounds to buy a house now and that house
will make you rich
eventually
but this is the problem with property
investing it's slow
it's like yeah you buy a house
and then you sit on it and you rent it
out
you rent it for a thousand pounds a
month but then you've got to pay the
mortgage payments the maintenance the
voids the insurance
your taxes you know you're not left with
a huge amount of money but the real
wealth in property is when it goes up in
value which can take years
so property investing is amazing but
it's not like
immediate cash in your pocket it's also
not very liquid
you know if you buy a house yeah you
know you can't just
flip it quickly it takes time you gotta
get slices involved and everything so
when i was like 23 i thought okay i'm
really good at packing uh finding deals
i'm really good at deal sourcing but i
wanna
get paid quickly you know i was getting
married and
um i wanted some cash i had to pay some
people back some of the loans and stuff
and i thought i just
i'm property rich but i'm kind of cash
poor
how can i get quick cash in my pocket so
i thought okay here's what i'll do i'm
gonna
find some deals
some really juicy deals
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
contact some of my friends who are
property investors that i know are
looking for deals they're like waiting
for the perfect deal and i'll broker the
deal
so i'll say look
if you want a deal
i'll find it but you can pay me like two
percent of the purchase price and for a
200 000 pound house which is very
standard you know two percent purchase
fee that's 4 000 pounds
so i had a few investors that were down
for it and to begin with i was very
sloppy i didn't have this as a
systemized business so to begin with i
was like you know
going out with like three investors at a
time and i was just showing them around
loads of different properties that were
on the market and i was just saying look
i've done my research in due diligence
i'm in with these agents i know we can
get a good price on this house this has
this house so i was like doing all the
donkey work and then i'd bring them with
me to go and see the houses and and it
was okay and some of them would pay me
and some of the girls would come off
some would not come off um but it was a
bit slow and it was actually one of my
business mentors
i've got to give a shout out to tony
crook um
but
you know one of my business mentors was
like hang on a minute you've got this
has got legs
rather than going and viewing some
houses and bringing some of the
investors with you and trying to why
don't you just go on your own
and view the houses
and put offers forward on the best
houses and then when the offer is
accepted
then send the send an email out
to your entire database of investors and
say i've just had an offer accepted on
this property
this is the purchase price these are the
figures this is the due diligence done
this is the research i've done on the
property and i want four grand and i
want it up front
and it's just a first-come first-served
basis no messing around
genuine urgency because it's not like
you're trying to rush someone to pay you
money for the sake of it you're saying
hey all right this deal i've just had an
offer accepted we need to get this
wrapped up the estate agent needs to
know who's buying it the estate agent
needs to know you know
the buyers proof of funds and
correspondence address and photo id and
solicitor details so like we need to get
this wrapped up now so
my fees four thousand pounds how would
you like to pay
so i'm like okay so i go and view some
this this was the day i can't remember
what what what the exact date was but i
remember i remember the day
when i'm like
holy moly i'm on to something and that
was when i went out
i viewed i don't know about 12 houses in
like one day and i put some offers
forward and i ended up getting four
properties um
offers on four properties all accepted
and i remember that evening i'm like
damn i got four houses
the estate agent has basically accepted
all my four offers they're really good
houses and i put together this email and
i just said i just put dear investors
i've just secured
these four deals
they're all in wolverhampton these are
the details and if you want to reserve
drop me a text and tell me which
property you want to reserve property
one woof and i'll put the details
you know it's a four bed hmo it's 85
grand it needs two grand renovation blah
blah blah blah blah it's gonna be this
much rent
hmm management company in place but
property two woof details property three
property four text me to reserve and
i'll call you up and take payment boom
bang sen sent the email out
and within like 20 minutes my phone is
just pinging ping ping ping ping with
investors that are just investors that i
just built organically over the years
friends families connections suppliers
people i've done business with people
that i'd met when i was just out
networking events i've collected their
business cards you know like not like
thousands of investors i'm talking like
maybe a couple hundred few hundred
so i send out this um email ping ping
ping ping ping ping i'm like
okay
this is crazy
okay so i'll call up the first guy speak
to him hey john john you said you wanted
to reserve property one
um i've got a contract which is going to
give you a 14-day calling period terms
and conditions about the about the
nature of this bit of this agreement
which i've got drawn above my sister i
was like so um
the fee's four grand
uh have you got any questions for me and
john's like no it sounds all good um
you know the property sounds good i
trust you and obviously i'd like i need
to see it and get survey on it and stuff
like that but i'm happy to pay the
reservation fee i'm like okay cool so
i'll send you an invoice you could pay
it maybe you know now
oh well yeah send me send an invoice
i'll get it paid the next few days
the thing is john
i've got an agent that's just accepted
the offer like i need to know who's
buying this in the morning i'm going to
need to give an answer to the agent of
who the buyer is so in order to reserve
it would would you be able to pay the
fee tonight
um yeah sure i'm getting paid tonight no
problem send me over the contract an
invoice okay cool so i sent it to john
but then one after i sent that to john i
get the next person call me up text me
sorry do i call up
i'm like okay i managed to make i made
12 000 pounds
in like one hour and i remember thinking
i went out i spent a day doing some
viewings i sent an email i just made 12
grand
could i do the same thing next week
could i do the same thing tomorrow
damn i'm on to something i've got a
business here and that was when i
absolutely blew up as a deal sorcerer
and i just started selling deals all
across the country shout out to a guy
called blair singer
but i single mentored me uh so many
people mentored me man i spent so much
money on going on training courses and
sales programs and
paying for mentorship and guidance
and i started doing deals all across the
country so rather than just
wolverhampton and then branch into
stoke-on-trent i then branched up to
sunderland newcastle i then went to
berkeley i was all over the place
finding good deals below market value
fixer-uppers hmo opportunities service
accommodation deals like different good
deals as well here's the rule i had as
well i used to have a rule that was i'll
never sell a deal that i wouldn't buy
myself
and people say well why don't you just
bite yourself then it's like because i
can't buy everything myself i can't buy
every good deal that i see
but i wouldn't sell something unless i
would legitimately buy a deal of that
same standard myself so i'm only selling
good deals i think it's really important
to do that to build reputation that's
how i built up a reputation um and
anyway yeah within by the age of 25 i
managed to sell over 250 deals and you
can do the math you know if you're
making three four grand a pop 250 deals
is a lot of money and that's how i
became a millionaire and then i used the
money that i made from deal sourcing uh
to go on holiday no just kidding no
although i did do that i remember like
i'm here's the thing though right now
i'm away right now i'm in las vegas
and
i'm just on my way to beverly hills
later on i'm staying at the beverly
hills hotel and you know i i do use my
people that say you know business people
that say make your money but then live
like a paw print invest all of it it's
like come on man life's too short i'm 31
years old i want to enjoy my life now so
if i'm making you know
ten grand from selling a deal or five
grand or whatever i'm making i'm not
gonna invest a whole lot of money i'm
gonna keep some of it to live a good
life but then i'm gonna invest the rest
you see um
[Music]
and i managed to systemize the business
so i managed to get a um
a a a a assistant that would help me go
out and do the viewings and do the
bookkeeping
and i remember you know just like
traveling all over the world thailand
dubai singapore
across asia india america california and
i'd be having people pay me i can send
that i can send that email from my phone
bank to my investors woof and then once
i sent an email out
they're going to text me i can call them
up i can be in america in fact it's
really good sometimes because the time
difference can really serve you well you
know because you like wake up
ah you wake up and it's like maybe 9am
here and you have a bit of a lie in but
then towards england it's like the end
of the day and you're able to just do
i'll work for like two hours
from nine till eleven but then in
england might be towards the end of the
day and then i'll spend the rest of the
day just relaxing hanging out i've made
my money that day
another thing is if you're if you're
packaging and selling deals
you've got you basically need four
things to package and sell deals you
need a list of investors you need to be
able to find good deals
you need the skills and the reputation
and the salesman skills for the
expertise to actually close the deal
and you need contracts you need to have
if ever you're taking money off anyone
ever or do any deal even with family you
need a contract
so that's it and when you've got those
skills
you could do the same thing in fact i've
helped a lot of people also get into
deal selling and selfishly you might say
why would i help people do the same
thing
you know well
a lot of my students that i teach this
strategy
bring me deals now
because now like i just had somebody um
a lady called marie marie if you're
watching i love you
she brought me this deal
which is a beautiful deal i paid a
refinder's fee but i want to make over a
million pounds profit on that one deal
so
you know for me having a community the
more people that are in property rather
than seeing that as competition i see
that as collaboration you know um the
great thing as well is if you've got
those four skills if you can if you have
the skills to sell you've got the
investors you've got the deals and
you've got the contracts
then you can also
join venture with people if you find a
really juicy deal instead of selling the
deal to the investor you can you can
partner with the investor and you can
say to the investor you put the money in
i found the deal i'll oversee it but
i'll take a profit share and you can
start building up your actual portfolio
without using any of your money which is
just amazing so
ultimately in business the more valuable
you become the more money you'll make
rather than chasing the money and
chasing the success chase the value the
reason i became a millionaire was
because there's a lot of investors out
there that wanted good deals but didn't
have the time
or the inclination or the energy or the
skill set
to be able to find those deals
so they're relying on estate agents and
estate agents are being paid by the
seller
so the estate agent of course the estate
agent's gonna say everything's a good
deal
here's a good deal here's a good deal
here's a good deal and the investor is
like oh man that is that a good deal
whereas i'm getting paid by the investor
so i'm working on behalf of the investor
i'm finding the best deals
so i'm adding value to the investor and
when you add value when you add value
the money will follow so that's the
strategy that i used to become a
millionaire obviously i've also been
investing in property for a long time
you know and um
you know when i started deal selling i
was already doing okay
but literally when i was at school i
failed i failed in school
and i
am not particularly academic but what i
have got going for me is good business
acumen and i think you know just to the
ability to keep going to not give up to
add value that's what will certainly
make me a millionaire so the reason i'm
shooting this video is just to inspire
people and to
give back i don't want to be one of
those rich people that then hide away i
want to be able to share and help and
inspire other people so if you've got
questions for me let me know i wish you
every success and i'll see you next time